oh well that's a long story so I was in
retailing I went to City College so I
went to fi t and i was in retailing for
a while and i was working for a company
called Gimbels in New York City and they
were going to close shop they sold the
real estate here right here on
thirty-third and broadway and i was out
of a job so I said oh you know I've
always been working since I'm like 16
years old I said I was married at the
time and I was able to take some time
off so I took some time off and some
friends of mine said to me let's open a
cabaret and I said oh that might be fun
so we opened this cabaret on eighth
Avenue in twenty sixth street and they
named to carolines well once my name was
on the door then I had a little more
than a vested interest in it so I said
oh this might be fun you know helping
run this club so we started with lots of
cabaret acts and when that quite it
really didn't hit me I mean it wasn't
contemporary enough for me at that time
then we started to book comedians like
Jay Leno and Jerry Seinfeld and Garry
Shandling and Billy Crystal and pee wee
herman and that was the start of
Caroline's as a comedy club Oh watching
the david letterman show that was on it
you know 1230 at night Jay Leno was kind
of a regular on that show so I kind of
said oh let me tie it into when if we
can get him on the show when he said
Caroline's then he can mention that he's
there and then people come out to see
him it was a way of saving with
advertising but getting the word out I
guess it was called marketing at that
time so kind of we did it that way and I
kind of built our reputation
he was a working comedian he worked
around the country he had a small
following at that time but they came out
to him and it was kind of my
contemporaries at the time Jay and I are
you know like the same age and his
clientele was the same age at that time
and and they came out to see him
followed by people that were on the rise
like Jerry Seinfeld and Garry Shandling
Sandra Bernhard Rita Rudner I mean it's
everybody that's kind of made it came
through the club I think I was talking
to an agent at that time at APA and
Jerry was there and he said well you
know agents are always trying to sell
you a challenge anyway so he suggested
that we we book Jerry and we did a Jerry
worked at the club for a number of years
and I remember him doing a few New
Year's Eves there so it was kind of fun
years ago I think a lot of people came
through our system you know a lot of
people where we had them as we put them
as opening acts I mean Chris yeah Chris
Rock was a young kid when he started to
work at the club and when he last
appeared at a club we had a young
comedian called wanda sykes and Wanda we
put wander as an opening act and
introduced her to Chris and after that
you know she kind of her career was made
and she worked in she worked a lot with
Chris with Chris Rock maybe I take it
for granted the people have come through
there I mean lots of producers larry
david michael patrick king Jon Stewart
Jon Stewart was a writer on the TV show
that I had for A&A for six years so it
was also him and michael patrick king i
mean what i look back at some of the fun
things that we did you know in the early
90s you can see where these guys were
headed to after that we start a lot of
people out there's a young woman Lisa
Lampanelli we we let her come in and let
her perform there and build her
following and she went on to do not to
be very funny lady so
things like that um I think how i watch
comedians I watched them grow Sunday
night I was watching the Oscars and I
watched Jon Stewart and I was thinking
last night I wanted to send him a note
you know I remember him as a 27 year old
kid standing with me at a bar at the
club that I had at the seaport you know
talking about his mother to me and you
know just to go back and to see how he's
grown over the years it's just quite
amazing that's almost 20 20 years ago
when I when I met John you know I did a
kiddie show with John at the seaport on
a saturday morning i wish i had the
tapes of that no he's grown he's grown
he's you know he's he has his own voice
he grew into himself he's he's just a
real real big big talent
you